Générique
- Alexandre Poussart:
Bonjour à tous.
Très heureux de vous retrouver
dans "Parlement hebdo", l'émission
qui revient sur l'actualité de la
semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Pour commenter
cette semaine sous haute tension,
le député Renaissance Sylvain
Maillard.
Vous êtes vice-président du groupe
Renaissance.
On va parler du sujet numéro 1,
les retraites.
- Alexandre Poussart: Elisabeth
Borne a décidé de passer en force
la réforme des retraites en
déclenchant l'article 49.3 de la
Constitution.
L'opposition a donc décidé de
déposer une motion de censure du
gouvernement.
Un texte transpartisan qui sera
discuté lundi.
Malgré l'utilisation du 49.3, le
Sénat avait adopté le texte final
de la réforme des retraites, fruit
d'un compromis entre 7 députés et
7 sénateurs de la commission mixte
paritaire.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est donc
l'épilogue d'une longue séquence
politique et parlementaire.
Ce jeudi 16 mars à 15h, Elisabeth
Borne a décidé de recourir à
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution
pour faire passer la réforme des
retraites.
- La parole est à madame la
Première ministre.
- C'est sous les huées des
oppositions, sous les paroles de
"La Marseillaise" entonnées par
les groupes de gauche et les
claquements de pupitre du
Rassemblement National
qu'Elisabeth Borne prend la
parole.
- C'est sur votre réforme, sur le
texte du Parlement, fruit d'un
compromis entre les deux
assemblées, que je suis prête à
engager ma responsabilité.
- Dans ce tumulte, la Première
ministre annonce le recours au
49.3.
- Aussi, sur le fondement de
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution,
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi de financement
rectificative de la Sécurité
sociale pour 2023.
- Une issue sans surprise, et
pourtant amère, pour les alliés de
la majorité.
- On est déçus parce qu'on voulait
aller au vote.
On voulait que la représentation
nationale puisse s'exprimer et que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités.
- Ce à quoi on vient d'assister,
c'est un simulacre de démocratie.
Ces gens-là préfèrent le 49.3
parce qu'ils n'auront pas besoin
d'exprimer leur vote.
Comme ça, ils sauvent ceux qui
sont contre, alors qu'ils ont,
aux présidentielles, soutenu la
retraite à 65 ans.
- Un rôle que refuse d'endosser
Les Républicains.
- Ils balayent d'abord leur
perron.
C'est inadmissible de nous faire
porter le chapeau.
Au sein du groupe de la majorité,
il y avait des défaillances.
- Pour La France Insoumise, ce
49.3 signe un échec du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron.
- Le combat est loin d'être fini.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un
basculement autoritaire.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le premier jour
du reste du quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron, de la fin du quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron.
- Un échec, c'est aussi ce que dit
le Front National.
- C'est incontestablement une
dénaturation de notre
fonctionnement démocratique.
Chacun admet que cette réforme est
brutale, injuste, inefficace et
injustifiée.
Madame Borne doit partir.
- Prochaine étape: les motions de
censure annoncées par des
oppositions.
- Kathia Gilder: Peu avant cette
décision, beaucoup dans votre
groupe appelaient à un vote, et
finalement, il y a le 49.3.
C'est un déni de démocratie?
- Sylvain Maillard: Depuis des
semaines, nous avons toujours dit
que nous voulions voter.
Mon groupe, derrière notre
présidente Aurore Bergé, avait
déjà dit publiquement son souhait.
Nous avons dit, les uns et les
autres, le souhait du groupe
extrêmement majoritairement
d'aller au vote.
- Kathia Gilder: Donc c'est une
grosse déception.
- Sylvain Maillard: Ce jeudi
matin, nous avons refait les
comptes avec les dirigeants du
groupe LR, Eric Ciotti et Olivier
Marleix.
Il nous manquait des voix.
Des députés LR qui se sont faits
élire il y a encore neuf mois sur
un projet à 65 ans ont décidé
d'être populaires et ont renié
leur histoire et leurs promesses.
Au fond, on était probablement à
une ou deux voix près, dans le
risque de ne pas faire passer
cette réforme qui est
indispensable.
Encore une fois, je vois que LR
n'est plus dirigé, en réalité.
Il y a des groupes LR à
l'intérieur du groupe.
Il y a une partie du groupe qui
est fidèle à son histoire, qui a
tenu la barre, et une autre partie
qui a totalement tourné le dos.
C'est devenu des baronnies
locales.
- Alexandre Poussart: Même avec
cette majorité incertaine, est-ce
qu'il fallait utiliser le 49.3?
Est-ce qu'il ne fallait pas
prendre le risque du vote?
- Sylvain Maillard: La
responsabilité, c'est de faire un
choix.
Tout le monde savait que nous
voulions aller au vote.
La responsabilité, c'est: est-ce
qu'il faut cette réforme pour la
France, oui ou non?
C'est ça, la question qui était
posée à la Première ministre.
En responsabilité, elle a choisi:
il était essentiel que cette
réforme passe pour sécuriser nos
pensions, pour faire en sorte que
l'on puisse sécuriser nos
retraités.
C'est ça qui a été choisi.
Oui, c'est impopulaire.
Une réforme des retraites, c'est
toujours impopulaire.
Mais nous sommes face à
l'histoire.
Il faut assurer le système des
retraites.
- Kathia Gilder: On parle de crise
sociale et politique qui risque de
s'aggraver.
Est-ce que vous redoutez une
paralysie du quinquennat?
- Sylvain Maillard: Nous sommes
dans une situation qui n'est pas
évidente.
Je le conçois.
En même temps, ce sont des outils
démocratiques, qui existent.
Le 49.3 a toujours existé.
Nous l'utilisons parce que c'est
important et essentiel que cette
réforme puisse se mettre en
oeuvre.
Dès cette année, on va pouvoir
commencer à revaloriser les
petites pensions.
Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
retraités qui attendaient ça
aussi.
C'est aussi ça qui se jouait.
C'est pas uniquement des lois en
chambre.
Il s'agissait de changer
concrètement la vie des retraités.
Grâce au travail que l'on a pu
faire en CMP, en commission mixte
paritaire, dont je faisais partie,
on a pu travailler toute une
journée très concrètement: comment
faire pour améliorer le texte?
Le texte présenté par Elisabeth
Borne en janvier et le texte qui
est actuellement passé en 49.3, ce
n'est pas tout à fait le même.
On a beaucoup amélioré le texte.
- Alexandre Poussart: Donc pour
vous, le 49.3 est un outil
démocratique?
Il est constitutionnel, mais dans
ce contexte, vous le trouvez
démocratique?
- Sylvain Maillard: Oui.
Je prends un peu de recul.
Nous avons été élus, les députés
et les sénateurs,
démocratiquement.
Nous avons l'autorité pour faire
des choix politiques que l'on
assume devant nos électeurs.
La rue a une légitimité, mais elle
n'a pas la légitimité qu'ont les
représentants de la nation.
Il ne faut pas faire d'amalgame.
Oui, il y a une difficulté.
Mais l'essentiel pour nous, pour
le pays, c'est de passer cette
réforme.
Donc nous utilisons les outils
démocratiques qui existent.
Il n'y a pas de coup de force.
Il y a juste une utilisation des
outils démocratiques.
- Kathia Gilder: Emmanuel Macron a
invoqué des risques financiers
trop grands pour se passer de
cette réforme.
Est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
fallait quelque part aussi
rassurer les marchés financiers
qui prêtent à la France?
- Sylvain Maillard: Dans tous les
journaux, vous commencez en
parlant de telle ou telle banque
qui est en difficulté.
Les taux d'intérêt ont beaucoup
augmenté ces derniers mois.
Les taux d'intérêt qui augmentent,
c'est entre 11 et 13 milliards
cette année qui partent pour la
France.
C'est énorme.
Ca correspond d'ailleurs au
déficit que l'on attend
pratiquement année après année
jusqu'en 2030 pour les retraites.
Ca part comme ça.
La donne a changé.
Il nous faut nous adapter.
Il faut sécuriser les pensions de
nos retraités, être sûr qu'elles
ne vont pas baisser dans le temps.
Donc les cotisations doivent payer
les pensions.
C'est ça, le système par
répartition.
Nous comprenons que ce soit
impopulaire.
Dans quelques années, comme les
réformes passées, on nous dira que
c'était nécessaire et qu'il
fallait le faire.
- Kathia Gilder: Mais à l'époque,
il y avait une majorité et une
crise financière.
- Sylvain Maillard: Il y avait
aussi une majorité de Français qui
étaient contre et il y avait des
manifestations.
- Alexandre Poussart: Une motion
de censure du gouvernement
transpartisane va être déposée par
l'opposition et discutée lundi.
Vous craignez qu'elle soit votée?
- Sylvain Maillard: Ce sera là, le
vote pour la réforme des
retraites.
Chacun devra se positionner, y
compris chez LR.
A priori, il n'y a pas de
majorité, parce qu'il y a quand
même une forme de responsabilité
au dernier moment qui arrive entre
autres chez certains Républicains.
Je crois qu'ils savent, au fond.
Ils l'ont défendu pendant
tellement d'années.
- Kathia Gilder: Pour vous, si on
vote pour la censure, ça veut
dire...
- Sylvain Maillard: Ca veut dire
qu'on vote contre la réforme des
retraites.
Le gouvernement s'est engagé...
- Alexandre Poussart: Ce n'est pas
la même chose de censurer le
gouvernement et de voter contre la
réforme des retraites.
- Sylvain Maillard: On est dans un
moment politique très fort, avec
des Français encore mobilisés,
même s'il y a moins de monde dans
la rue.
C'est un groupe indépendant qui
porte cette motion.
Ca aura un impact sur la réforme.
- Kathia Gilder: L'utilisation de
ce 49.3 risque quand même de
conduire à une radicalisation du
mouvement syndical, qui se
présente sous une bannière unie.
Est-ce que vous craignez un
embrasement du pays?
- Sylvain Maillard: J'appelle à la
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales, qui ont été
extrêmement dignes, qui ont
manifesté partout en France dans
le calme.
Je veux le saluer.
On a continué à travailler avec
les organisations syndicales.
D'un point de vue local,
l'ensemble des députés Renaissance
ont continué à tenir langue avec
nos contacts locaux,
départementaux, régionaux,
nationaux, pour certains d'entre
nous.
Il y aura une loi travail, après.
Ce que nous avons entendu dans la
rue, certains nous parlent des 64
ans, c'est ce qui a peut-être
cimenté le mouvement, mais on a
aussi beaucoup entendu des gens
nous dire qu'ils voulaient
travailler mieux.
Donc comment faire pour adapter le
travail pour que plus de Français
aient envie de travailler et se
sentent mieux au travail?
On ne parle pas de deux ans de
prison, comme on a pu le dire sur
les bancs de la NUPES.
Il y a une vraie réflexion à
faire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'à
partir de maintenant, Emmanuel
Macron doit parler avec les
syndicats, alors que la
mobilisation contre cette réforme
des retraites va être relancée par
ce 49.3?
- Sylvain Maillard: La discussion
avec les syndicats n'a jamais été
coupée.
Beaucoup de réformes que nous
avons portées et votées à la
commission mixte paritaire sont
portées entre autres par la CFDT,
qui refuse la paternité ou n'en
parle pas, notamment sur l'index
senior.
Mais il y a un point dur, c'est
les 64 ans.
On peut continuer à parler, mais
ils nous disent une seule chose:
"Tant que vous ne retirez pas ça,
il ne se passera rien."
La loi demande un effort
supplémentaire aux Français, c'est
vrai, en travaillant deux ans de
plus, mais le reste, c'est que de
l'amélioration du système actuel.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
du fond de ce texte final de la
réforme des retraites, qui a quand
même été adopté par le Sénat jeudi
matin.
Ce texte a été le fruit d'un
compromis entre les 7 députés et
les 7 sénateurs de la commission
mixte paritaire.
- Au moment de valider le texte
issu de la commission mixte
paritaire à la chambre haute, la
rapporteure générale n'a pas fait
mystère qu'elle considérait ce
texte comme une victoire des
arguments de longue date de la
majorité sénatoriale.
- Vous retrouverez dans le texte
qui vous est présenté les
principales mesures que nous avons
examinées et adoptées tout au long
de la semaine dernière.
Même pour certaines, depuis
plusieurs années dans le cadre des
PLFSS.
- C'est donc logiquement que le
vote a été largement favorable à
cette version issue de la CMP,
avec 193 voix pour et 114 contre.
Même le ministre a défendu les
ajouts de la droite à l'issue de
ce vote.
- Ce texte a été amélioré par le
débat parlementaire, avec une
mesure favorable aux femmes qui
ont une carrière complète, avec
une meilleure prise en compte de
la pénibilité, avec de nombreux
amendements qui permettent de
renforcer les droits, de faciliter
la vie des assurés et d'aller vers
un système de retraite à la fois
équilibré et amélioré.
- Au moment de voir qui a le plus
pesé dans les débats, l'un des
artisans de cette réforme version
sénatoriale était plus que
satisfait des mesures conservées.
- Un mixte à la fois de volonté
exprimée à l'Assemblée nationale à
travers notamment les carrières
longues, pour lesquelles il était
nécessaire d'avoir une durée de
cotisation appropriée, et côté
Sénat, où nous avions travaillé
sur l'usure professionnelle, sur
l'employabilité des seniors, et
nous avons obtenu satisfaction.
- A gauche en revanche, la pilule
est amère, avec bien peu
d'amendements conservés de leur
côté.
- Le gouvernement a lâché beaucoup
de choses pour s'assurer du vote
des Républicains, et tout cela sur
le dos des salariés.
L'objectif de la CMP, ça n'était
pas d'adoucir le projet de loi,
c'était d'éviter au gouvernement
et au président de la République
de perdre la face.
- Un texte de compromis entre la
droite et le gouvernement voté au
Sénat, mais qui n'aura pas suffi à
trouver une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale.
- Alexandre Poussart: Malgré ces
améliorations apportées par la
négociation entre le Sénat et le
gouvernement, qu'est-ce qui a
manqué à ce texte pour qu'il soit
accepté par une plus grande
majorité de députés et de
Français?
- Sylvain Maillard: C'est très
difficile de porter une réforme
des retraites.
J'ai commencé en 2017 à
l'Assemblée nationale.
C'est la seconde réforme que nous
portons.
Nous avons porté une autre réforme
avec Edouard Philippe.
C'est très difficile parce qu'en
réalité, ce sont des sujets très
techniques.
Les retraites, c'est 42 régimes
différents, avec des spécificités.
C'est très technique.
D'ailleurs, je voudrais saluer nos
rapporteurs, Stéphanie Rist pour
l'Assemblée nationale et Elisabeth
Doineau au Sénat, pour le travail
en commun mais aussi pour leurs
connaissances et ce qu'elles ont pu
apporter aux débats qui ont été
calmes et constructifs.
La journée a été longue, mais on a
vraiment pu travailler et aller
dans le détail.
Au fur et à mesure du temps de la
CMP, les oppositions étaient de
moins en moins virulentes, parce
qu'il y avait des explications
données.
Très souvent, quand on en parle,
on parle d'une mesure.
La seule chose qui a imprimé dans
l'opinion publique, ça a été la
mesure d'âge.
C'est vrai qu'on demande de
travailler plus, comme dans tous
les pays européens autour de nous.
On n'a rien inventé.
On est plutôt en retard par
rapport aux autres.
Il faut travailler plus pour
garantir des cotisations
suffisantes au niveau des
pensions.
Tout le reste, ce sont des
améliorations.
Et toutes ces améliorations, on
n'a pas réussi à pouvoir les faire
entendre.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
admettez quand même un déficit de
pédagogie?
Pendant tout ce débat, on a
entendu beaucoup de ministres et
de députés de la majorité qui
disaient que c'était une réforme
juste.
Est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
plutôt dire quelque chose comme:
"C'est une réforme pénible, mais
il n'y a pas le choix"?
- Sylvain Maillard: Je ne juge pas
les communications des uns et des
autres.
Dans mon groupe, 37 députés
différents ont pris la parole
pendant toute cette phase dans les
médias nationaux, locaux, à la
télévision, à la radio.
Il y a eu une explication, ils ont
été là, ils ont expliqué.
C'est une réforme d'efforts, je
l'ai toujours dit.
On demande des efforts aux
Français qui le peuvent pour
garantir un niveau de pension.
Pour avoir une retraite digne.
Après, il y a une question
politique.
C'est le débat que l'on aurait
voulu avoir à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Est-ce qu'on veut baisser le
chômage?
Oui.
Depuis 2017, on a une politique
très claire.
Oui, moins de taxes et moins
d'impôts.
Moins on a d'impôts, moins on a de
taxes, moins on a de cotisations,
moins on a de chômage.
Ce n'est pas une question
d'efforts.
Nous sommes déjà le pays qui taxe
le plus.
Nous sommes le pays qui a les plus
fortes cotisations.
Nous sommes déjà le pays qui a les
plus importantes.
Est-ce que ça marche mieux?
Non.
Il faut être réaliste.
Regardons ce qui se fait autour de
nous.
Les Allemands travaillent jusqu'à
67 ans, les Espagnols et les
Italiens entre 65 et 66 ans.
Si on veut garder un système par
répartition, il nous faut
travailler plus.
Les Français travaillent moins que
les autres.
Depuis 20 ans, nous avons passé
l'idée un peu folle qu'au fond, le
progrès, c'était de travailler
moins.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
Nous avons besoin de travailler
plus, en tout cas ceux qui le
peuvent doivent travailler un peu
plus, et en échange, ceux qui sont
usés doivent pouvoir partir plus
tôt.
- Kathia Gilder: On va terminer
avec cette première à l'Assemblée
nationale.
La commission d'enquête
parlementaire visant à établir la
perte de souveraineté énergétique
de la France auditionnait en plein
49.3 deux anciens présidents de la
République, Nicolas Sarkozy puis
François Hollande.
- Quand vous, les politiques, vous
avez peur du nucléaire, vous
envoyez un signal que vous allez
détruire cette filière, parce que
l'arrêter, c'est la détruire,
c'est comme si vous m'expliquiez
que l'Atlantique, l'océan Indien
et le Pacifique ne connaissent pas
le phénomène de la marée.
Avec le nucléaire, vous reculez.
Vous vivez où vous mourrez.
C'est ça, la filière technologique
de haute intensité.
- C'est parce qu'il y a des
difficultés dans la filière
nucléaire, c'est parce que
précisément, elle fait face à de
nombreuses réparations qui sont
nécessaires ou parce que la
vigilance doit être accrue, que
nous devons la défendre.
C'est ce que j'ai fait tout au
long de mon mandat, défendre la
filière nucléaire tout en
souhaitant travailler pour qu'elle
puisse être complétée par une
montée des énergies renouvelables.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a donc eu
ces deux auditions ce jeudi 16
mars, au moment où le 49.3 a été
déclenché.
D'un côté, Nicolas Sarkozy s'est
posé en ardent défenseur du
nucléaire.
De l'autre, François Hollande a
décidé de fermer Fessenheim.
Qui des deux présidents a la
meilleure stratégie sur le
nucléaire?
- Sylvain Maillard: Je n'ai pas
envie de donner des points.
Il est toujours très simple de
donner son avis 10 ans après.
Ces deux auditions ont montré que
face à des décisions à prendre, il
y avait un contexte qui expliquait
leur décision.
Dans les extraits que j'ai pu
voir, j'ai trouvé qu'ils ont tous
les deux été très pédagogiques.
Ils ont expliqué pourquoi ils ont
pris leur décision.
- Kathia Gilder: Avec sincérité
aussi?
- Sylvain Maillard: J'en ai le
sentiment, oui.
D'abord, c'est un beau message
pour nous.
Nous devons prendre des mesures
pour la suite, pour les 20 années
qui arrivent.
Nous serons peut-être à leur place
dans quelque temps pour expliquer
nos choix.
Les choix sont compliqués.
Je suis un homme d'entreprise, qui
vient aussi d'un secteur
technologique.
C'est toujours facile de faire les
guerres après.
Je vois à quel point l'opinion
s'est retournée depuis quelques
mois, elle est devenue très
pro-nucléaire, alors qu'il y avait
plutôt une intention d'en sortir.
Il y a un principe de réalité.
Nous avons besoin de beaucoup plus
d'électricité dans les années qui
viennent.
Il va donc falloir produire
beaucoup plus.
On ne peut pas produire
d'hydrogène si on n'a pas
énormément d'électricité.
Nous restions sur le choc qu'a été
Fukushima, qui a profondément
marqué chacun d'entre nous.
On s'est dit qu'on allait pouvoir
vivre uniquement avec du
renouvelable.
Il faut du renouvelable.
On a porté une loi pour accélérer
le renouvelable.
Mais il va falloir plus de
nucléaire.
Dans leur deux sincérités, ils ont
pu expliquer des décisions.
Ca nous éclaire aussi sur les
décisions à prendre pour l'avenir.
- Alexandre Poussart: Emmanuel
Macron a aussi suivi ce
retournement de l'opinion sur le
nucléaire.
Dans le premier quinquennat, il
était plutôt sur une trajectoire
de réduction du nucléaire.
Maintenant, il est plutôt sur une
trajectoire de relance.
- Sylvain Maillard: La filière du
nucléaire était en danger.
Nicolas Sarkozy a raison
là-dessus.
Dans l'industrie, ou vous êtes en
avant ou vous vous arrêtez.
On avait un sentiment qu'au fond,
à travers EDF, la tête de file de
la filière nucléaire française, on
était plutôt dans un moment où on
allait démanteler les filières
nucléaires et qu'il n'y avait plus
de stratégie de long terme.
Il fallait remettre une stratégie.
Mais on n'appuie pas sur un
bouton, il faut revoir totalement
la filière.
Il va falloir du temps pour la
réorganiser.
S'il n'y a pas de volonté
politique inscrite dans le long
terme, ce n'est pas possible.
C'est ça qu'a fait Emmanuel
Macron.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va jeter
un oeil à l'agenda de la semaine
prochaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Conséquence de
l'utilisation du 49.3, lundi aura
lieu le débat sur l'une des
motions de censure déposées, celle
des députés du territoire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les
sénateurs vont débattre d'une
proposition de loi concernant les
violences intrafamiliales.
C'est la fin de cette émission.
- Kathia Gilder: A la semaine
prochaine.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA